[Music]
he can reserve was beneath the size
including an overgrown child paddock
into a place where visitors could rest
and relax the natural environment would
be restored native son the blind freeze
the birds and fish to return the people
of the neighboring school south of
primary and running order new life would
use it for learning 40 of these in
recreation you can reserve as a resource
that fits beautifully with our souls
free today knowledge character in
relationships we use it to develop
knowledge of our environment and the
social sciences the sciences end for a
few you covet ease it allows the
supposed to chill giving children a
chance to be outside to meditate to be
creative on your thinking there is a
place to work for the community the part
of team activities and to boob and
native environments all building
relationships southbridge school is
proud to be part of the he can resume
the thinking was paid for by the
community board as was the year 13
students darryl hanah sculpture little
book which symbolizes the character of
the screen of the wines of way through
the newly formed reserve the poem even
reserved installed at the infant was
written by South Brook pupils dental
killers who speaks of her vision for the
future of the reserve kids are laughing
dogs barking sound of joyful where the
creative babbling scorching heat
pedaling through the planning and
efforts of pupils of south of primary
school and rank your new life school and
guidance from the council's green court
and running water community board
amazing progress has been made profile
he given reserve the place to be technic
hammock friends and family our board
look forward to continuing to work with
schools in the wider community and
making legal reserve and environmental
pressure the generations to come
[Music]